[Music]
seeing as the for honor Bader is closing
on Sunday I feel like I should give my
personal opinion on this date and give
it kind of my thoughts now some of these
will be my personal opinion seeing as
this is my review so just take some of
this for the grain of salt if you would
but I'm not going to be totally biased
in this you know i'm not going to only
have only good stuff or only bad stuff
i'm going to have a little bit of bowls
because not everything is perfect but
not everything is garbage so the first
thing about the first thing we'll be
talking about is a good thing the great
things that Ubisoft did was for honor is
that they have amazing graphics
especially during the intro costume when
you first saw off the game and even in
game they was just stunning now there
was a video a long time ago of every
game ubisoft is made and how it
downgraded from a trailer to the game
but seeing as i played the beta and they
kind of look similar I'm completely fine
with it another great thing that they
have is the amazing amount of
customization you can have with each
character now if none of you has played
this video I'll go over this basically
you have nine different heroes three
people from three different groups three
Vikings three nights and three samurais
they all have certain things you can
customize their chest piece their arms
their helmet and then depending on their
weapons you know certain things like for
example one of the samurai girls Nobu
she you can customize your staff or
blade and the little guard at the top
but the Berserker for the Vikings you
can customize the left hip the left arm
the right arm and then the handle it all
depends on the weapon they use that they
all get certain things you can customize
depending on like what you get from
these from the loot that you get at the
end of the game you could get you know
an increase in damage or but a decrease
in defense everything that you get is
always a positive but a negative for
example one of the blades for your
weapon might have you know increased
damage would decreased attack or a
helmet could have regeneration increased
but like your throw distance is negative
they all have these certain pause
is a negative that kind of makes it kind
of it's not really a grind but it could
be worth it and even if you don't want
to put in this grind you can go to that
specific hero go to scavenge here and
then you can pay 300 400 to 500 steal
just to get you know certain items for
them that you want is like the 300
package is three random items the 400
packs are specific in a 400 steel for
just only weapon parts or only armor
parts and the premium pack is 500 will
give you five different items and two of
them are guaranteed high level three are
probably going to be living on a low
tier like you know level one and two the
two hires are probably going to be like
for maybe a fives are lucky I like this
kind of customization because it kind of
separates you know certain characters
and then also can put in certain built
like for example you could have I don't
know erator for example he can have an
intense borough distance but not as
great attack or he could be a glass
cannon which is a [ __ ] ton of attack and
not a lot of defense you know go in take
a few swings come back and kind of sneak
it you know do little poke damage here
in there it'll at least all these
different ideas for all these different
builds is such a great idea that they
came up with another thing they have
which is good and bad is faction more
faction wars a game-mode we're basically
at the very beginning of the game you
pick your favorite faction whether
that's nice Vikings of samurais then you
fight with that faction to see who can
control the most amount of land in the
13-day spam that they actually have
going on for this section one now seeing
is this is a beta it's only going to go
on for a couple days not the whole 13
but every time you win or lose a game
you can deploy your war assets to either
guard a certain position or attack a
certain position you have a problem with
this though is that the faction wars a
little bit confusing to start out like I
still don't really know what like
because this percentage is whenever you
go to certain tiles whether it's like
for example you could be at one tile and
there it could say forty nine percent
for the Knights and then like fifty
three percent for the samurais I don't
know what any of that means to be honest
because they don't really use faction
world that often even though I really
should but some of its like super
using to me and I'm probably going to
figure it out and I you know a couple
hours or so but it's all I can really
tell you is that it's a little bit
confusing at first but it's a very great
idea that they came up with another
thing I like about this is that it gives
that old nostalgic feel like old combat
you know how all those old combat movies
of like the samurai night service any
like any night medieval movie or
medieval game all that [ __ ] you know it
just gives you that boldness bed
nostalgic feeling in it the combat feels
like really smooth and not walking you
can't really give your you can't really
have the excuse that all I was lagging
that's so the only way he killed me
since this game has peer to peer
connection and I'm get into that why
that's a very bad problem we're still in
like we're still on the good parts here
but the last thing is is if the player
leaves like let's say you're enough
because it's a 4v4 your player leaves he
gets her place to the bot and I your
kind of handicapped you know three
before but the bot is actually very
useful in this game they scaled the boss
from a level of one to three and they
keep the box at level 2 during PvP games
whenever a person leaves and the bots
actually very useful he's not as great
as like a really good player like a
really good player could easily destroy
a boss but he's there just to provide
some poke damage and kind of piss off
another player they're pretty useful
surprisingly it's one of the few games
that I've played that a bot is super
difficult or like very annoying usually
bothell by in a couple hits and then you
move on to the next one but now that
we're good now that we're done with the
good talk about the bad in my personal
opinion I do don't I really don't like
certain characters for example not a big
fan of orochi or you orochi fans out
there not hating you I just don't like
the character too many times I've do
those in a row Chi that you know can
swing right and swing left and swing up
immediately and it's super hard to
defend now it could just be me and I
kind of have to get used to it but it
does certain things completely after you
release a game something is going to get
different now something's going to get
difficult there's always going to be
that one care
actor or 1 items that's super meta and
that's really good I feel like the
samurais are kind of fallen in that
category just a little bit I want to
hear your personal opinion on that
whether you agree with me on that or not
now to what I was talking about a mess
appeared to peer connection if you don't
know peer to peer connection is it
basically takes the whole Lobby and then
gives the person with the best
connection is hope once that host leaves
then it will basically connect to a
different host of the best connection
the problem is is that it's not really a
smooth transition the host will leave
and then it will the game will freeze
for about five to ten seconds and then
it will say receiving network connection
and then it will find the best toast and
then it will give it to one other player
I had an instance where we were at the
very end of the game for v4 and they
were done they were basically now one
life left we got them over a thousand
points they were about to lose no big
deal problem was is that once we killed
the one guy the guy must have got super
pissed and left the game but then he
left the game and that caused the game
to refine another network connection
which then traveled to someone else on
his team and that player left and then
it spiraled this whole conjunction of
[ __ ] and then the game ended up crashing
and then we all had to go back to the
main menu and I didn't get the win they
didn't lose we didn't win it was just
like we never played the match that's
why I feel like they should add
dedicated servers so that everyone
connects to a Ubisoft server and none of
this will happen although there might be
a little bit of a lag issue so that's
why the peer-to-peer is a little bit
better but I do believe that a dedicated
server will definitely improve this game
a lot now the next one is that there's
not too many maps for the Dominion game
mode I've only played on like three maps
now to be fair they are the same map but
the only different climate you know
whether it's night day for me and I know
this is just a beta because you know it
usually betas don't have too many maps I
understand that because they're not
going to release the full game just for
a beta and then they're just you're just
going to get a reskin of them because
the full game already in beta stage
they're going to release a few things I
understand this
but just a little bit last maps for the
Dominion mode but you know they're
always going to change it this is just
another personal thing another one is
that certain characters to me feel a
little bit too weak for example i've
been playing warden basically the whole
beta I'm reputation one with them and I
feel like him compared to Ken say who is
the Vanguard Samurai and warden is the
Vanguard night so they're basically the
same character doesn't even different
factions you know different type of
swords and muta deaths if you look at
each other's move said Ken today has
three unblockable attacks just by doing
a combo the only problem with warden
here is that he needs to do a certain
combo which is light attack guard brake
light attack guard break and it's just
repetitive he can do he can do another
guard break but it's a little bit of a
harder combo to pull off ken say just
has to do a three-hit combo with the
right trigger involved somewhere in that
equation and you can get one some of
these characters like I'm saying feel a
little bit too weak to me like some of
them I think it's necessary to have an
unblocked attack if you know how to do
the combos because then it rewards you
for knowing how to do these combos but
some of them don't have two great combos
and they just feel super weak to me
that's really all I have to say for this
data just a quick overall recap the game
looks great the customization is great
everything about this is nice the only
thing that need to change is maybe
update a few of the characters you know
I don't want to say nerve for buff
because i know it's only a beta but just
my personal opinion some of them feel
little bit too strong for me that might
just be my lack of skill that's
completely fine and then they need to
figure out the peer-to-peer and
dedicated server connection stuff
because that will probably kill this
game very quickly now i'm sure some of
you have already dealt with that you've
already been in games and then you've
just completely lag out of the game for
no apparent reason whether it was a
start or the end or even in the middle
of the match for no random reason i had
it just a few minutes ago before making
this when I was middle of I was in the
middle of an execution and then I got
quit out of the game because the person
I killed it's just the little things
like that
can kind of really piss off a player and
make them stop playing a good game and I
don't want I don't want this game to you
know die super quickly it's a good game
Ubisoft has this tendency to have a lot
of hit or miss games assassins creed or
for you of them were hits Rainbow six
siege was definitely a hit the first
watchdog was kind of a Miss although I
did enjoy it watch bugs to did
definitely step it up though and i hope
this game doesn't also fall into the
category of a Miss because this game is
very great for what it has anyway I hope
y'all did enjoy like this video if you
did and then comment your opinion down
below of any other options or any other
things that you thought were good or bad
about this I'd love to hear your opinion
and then if you want to see more for our
videos subscribe if you're new and then
to the people that previously sub to me
because I've made titanfall videos i
know i'm not bugging the titanfall just
yet i'm going to be doing more soon just
the four armor beta was out and I really
want to get this video out because it
was really a types of this game don't
worry about that alright see you get
details